now you know what i need to do i need to
review some uh some scams too
like bernie madoff scam yeah you know
like uh um
sam israel scam like jeffrey epstein
epstein yeah yeah
i probably should you should do that
right now i don't know i don't know
anything i just look the only
it's hot right now i know it's hot
you've got the clicks on just that girl
it that was so funny on the
uh what's her name the epstein chick oh
the no i thought she meant the porno
chick that he
oh no he interviewed no he's talking
about the the interview we did with sean
atwood
where he was talking about gizland
elaine maxwell
oh okay he was talking about because
he's like covered the epstein
case front and he thinks he was killed
and right oh well he was definitely he
was definitely killed i mean it's i
don't even think it's conspiracy
what do you think man when we dropped
the video too when she got arrested so
it was in the news and it was just
you know the coincidence of the headline
and her in the news and it just blew up
in our little dinky channel that had
six thousand subscribers doubled in five
days and now we have like
yeah yeah now i have like 13 minutes and
it's blowing yeah it blew up
it's just it's it's sean covers
all that stuff like the war on drugs
like
he is he knows every little bit
about like the corrupt history of the
united states it's crazy
and the uh the epstein stuff's hot right
now so everyone's everybody's interested
in the episode stuff
especially because that elaine lady just
got arrested what do you think is going
to happen to her
i don't even know who this is i i know i
saw she was his like right-hand man
so she helped bring in the chicks she
procured all the girls so like
but it was like his girlfriend kind of
too yeah well weren't they all
yeah um but like his main show piece one
my my problem is i
it would be you know despite
and i haven't i haven't looked at
anything
but i've been in holdovers and i've been
in you know pins and mediums and lows
and you're not pulling off a murder in
there
unless you paid an inmate or a guard to
do it
right and i just don't see and i
understand they can say well the coroner
said that his neck was it stop it
the fact of the matter is you would have
had to have gotten and i understand the
camera didn't work
[ __ ] half the cameras don't work the
point is is that you would have had to
have gone
the only way to pull it off you went and
you got a guard yeah
you paid the guard to go into his to
disable the cameras
the guards are [ __ ] retards okay
they're not disabling [ __ ] maybe they
just shut them off but they're not going
to
break them in a way that they look like
they've been breaking they didn't break
them six months earlier or two months or
tell me that the camera just happened to
stop working 20 minutes before the thing
i don't see that so you so somebody a
guard has to go in
kill him in such a way that it looks
kill him they're saying one of
his cellmate killed him okay did they
charge the cellmate
well obviously they're not saying his
they're saying he committed suicide the
prison is saying that
okay but the conspiracy is
killed how did they contact the how they
contacted celly
to get them to they got to be powerful
enough to get there how did they
you don't think it's you don't think
it's possible to get all the people you
just dirty
did you see the his cellmate that they
put him with no i'm sure he was a beast
the dude was like an ex-cop [ __ ]
gorilla on steroids
[ __ ] massive okay humanoid the dude
was in
like snapped the guy's neck so easily
so why so why wouldn't they prosecute
him
why wouldn't they are you telling me all
these people are investigating we need
the transfer
anybody seen how the connection between
this guy and where's the money and
where's this and where's that
i just don't and i don't know much about
it but the base i base it but i know
the bureau of prisons and i know you're
just not gonna be able to make a phone
call and get someone to murder somebody
that's a hell of a leap
and maybe you know and look maybe i'm
wrong i don't think so
but i also know and the bone the the
bone
in his neck that was snapped they said
there's no way
that that bone is never breaks by just
strangulate by just someone hanging
themselves so i have a question
the corner that did his neck was
literally snap like for that bone to be
broken and there had to have been some
severe i understand they said what did
the coroner
that researched him that researched the
whole thing and that actually
looked at the body what did he say i
don't know for sure but i know that bone
was broken
i know there was i i'm i'm sure but
what's funny is it's it's easy to be an
armchair quarterback
and be an armed quarterback wow that's a
great that's a great one matt
three thousand three thousand miles away
did you
huh you roasted him well i'm saying
[Laughter]
you're three thousand miles away some
guy's three thousand miles away has a
degree in or
is a pulmonary specialist you know like
like in lungs
and he's telling a coroner that looks at
you know six bodies a day
that this bone could never be really
because the guy that looked at the
actual body
said this and he doesn't work for the
bop and he doesn't work for
the government the actual coroner is
saying it was
saying that that bone was broken so he's
okay i understand he's saying it's
broken so you're saying he's saying he
was strangled or is he saying it was
suicide
he's saying it was broken and it's
suicide some guy 3 000 miles away or
across the planet is saying
that bone is broken it's never broken uh
in any other cases
ever [ __ ] right okay and uh oh that
means it was that means someone choked
into death come on bro stop you don't do
you don't you're pulmonary you don't
think a coroner could be paid off to
to to fake what the cause of death was
hanging off everybody
i mean if anybody could be you know the
corner is probably the easiest one to
pay off
i think that if i was in the
administration
and that i knew that he had this
information and i knew this and i was
concerned and i was this and i was in
the inside and i could pull this off
i'd have killed that [ __ ] before
they cops ever got there
because that's who i am i know right you
know this
you know i can get in the bop and i can
get the guard to do this and i can
contact this guard and like why didn't
you just kill him before he was
when he was indicted when he was on home
confinement when he was coming back and
forth
to the to the um court why didn't you
just have when he was
being able to be seen by his uh by his
lawyer
there's a thousand ways to kill him i
think that they thought as well as
epstein i think he
truly believed as well as probably a lot
of people he was probably convincing
everybody around him that he was going
to be able to get out of there
without being without being convicted of
anything just like he had done
already you know there's a whole other
theory that he's still alive
you know there was a whole yeah there
was a whole other thing where people
were saying like they couldn't
the body was removed by somebody and
they don't know who took the body and
there was
i saw a whole thing on this and it was
like what
they're talking about how he's still
alive somewhere i mean there are nut
jobs
everywhere people believe all kinds of
stuff
right but you're saying that it's
extremely difficult it would be
extremely difficult
for somebody to murder him and cover it
up right
yeah to murder him i don't think that
that's that far to murder him
it would be difficult let me give you an
example in coleman
let me give you an example and coleman
okay but coleman is nowhere near what
this prison is
no no but it may not be near it but the
the basic facility designs
are all pretty similar and and the
security procedures are pretty similar
really this thing's like a tower
the one in the one in new york city uh i
mean
i understand but you're not suggesting
someone broke in and killed him you're
saying that
somebody told right right to kill him
and he did but the layout the layout of
the prison is completely different of
the metropolitan prison and
we're not talking about someone breaking
in or leaving or getting in you're now
saying no no they got to a guy that
actually was able to put his hands on
him so all they had to do was get him a
message
and convince him to kill the guy right
exactly i mean that's a pretty [ __ ]
that's a powerful argument i mean that's
a powerful
the art this to suggest it this is a guy
was that guy got a life sentence
that his selling i wonder where that guy
is now that guy that was his cellmate at
the time
because he's probably going i didn't
kill anybody what are you talking about
has anybody i wonder if anybody's talked
to him where he is right now that he's
getting a ton of letters from
these from these guys saying this and
then you know hey
can you call us on the b.o.p phone and
talk and yeah can we do an interview
we'll send you a thousand dollars if
you'll just answer some
you know it's he's probably like look at
these crack boxes i'm surprised he's not
doing interviews i'd be taking the
thousand dollars left and right yeah
yeah i'll call you at five
we can do an interview all he's got to
do is take the thousand dollars put the
thousand
on my books and say no i didn't kill him
what are you talking about leave me
alone
i mean i'm saying it's it
it is difficult to do that and when
those types of things happen let's say
the guy gets does get killed
there was a co in coleman a female co
who actually uh and i want to say was in
the pen
actually told
one of the guys one of the inmates
was she was in the shoe and one of the
inmates was giving her a hard time
and you know the inmates in shoes
they'll just say disgusting things to to
the female guards
so this one guard was one inmate was
giving her a hard time and she actually
took another inmate that was more
friendly to her and
put him in the other guy's cell and when
she put him in there in the cell she
said
break his legs or break his arm
the guy got in there and he basically
tries to like break his arm or something
right they get into a huge fight
the other guy doesn't allow him to break
his arm he puts up a fight
the other guy ends up choking him to
[ __ ] death
kills him well then of course the fbi
comes in
because they can't let sis invest they
can't investigate something like that so
the fbi comes in they investigate the
whole thing other guys here
overheard stuff whatever uh the guy ends
up saying okay this is what happened he
tells what happened
um this the female ceo they go to her
they tell her look we understand this is
what happened there's a camera we can
see you talking we know this you know
that
we're gonna give you a plea take like
five or ten years
you'll go to prison that's it she says
no no i didn't know this was going to
happen this is what i
no no no no she didn't obviously know
how the federal system works
so she goes to trial she loses she gets
like a [ __ ] 30 years or a life
sentence
so that's that's my my basic
understanding of the case
this is a female guard that told a guy
to have to to just break the guy's arm
and the whole thing unraveled
immediately
right how would this not have unraveled
immediately i mean
there's [ __ ] powerful people that
wanted him dead people want to believe
that prince
andrew the clintons i think that's fake
there's pictures of them hanging out
with
prince andrew what about what does that
mean what do you mean what does it mean
he they had they had the dude
there's a woman who was like 16 or 17
years old
who has a picture with prince andrew and
gillane maxwell and jeffrey epstein
in their house in london oh
i was underage and she says that she was
raped by him i understand
okay so i love the way you're going off
track here so now we're
not going off transparency did prince
andrew break in and kill him
no i'm just saying that this epstein had
dirt evidence on prince andrew so kill
him beforehand
look the guy got the guy beat his case
in florida he did a little bit of time
he got off on it he whatever
he kept touching the girls and he ended
up getting a federal charge got jammed
up but he got away with it once
if you knew he had all this stuff and
you knew that information was out there
and you were capable of pulling this off
why wouldn't you have killed him when he
was in his own house
you could have one guy go up shoot him
in the [ __ ] head he'd be done instead
you wait for him to get jammed up again
go to prison get it no i think he was
really valuable he wanted to keep going
to the party he's on the island no i
think he was really
killing it yeah then there's no more
party no i think epstein still had a lot
of value to them and they i think they
probably truly believed that he would be
able to get out of it
i mean look i think maybe it got too
late they said [ __ ] it we gotta pull the
plug
look one i like i said i don't know
anything about it okay
yeah it but what i am saying and by the
way
i would nobody would love to tell you
that the government is [ __ ] up and
nobody would like
nobody more than me would like to say oh
they this you know their scumbags you
know this you know
the truth is they're going about their
business and and i don't see
anybody pulling off murdering this guy
and i think that if the bop
was thought that he was actually killed
they would have charged the other guy
they would charge the cell they've been
like
how easy is that this is the guy that
killed him the guy's name was nicholas
tartaglioni tartaglione who's been
he was a cop in westchester county
and he was charred in 2000
in 2016 he was charged with deaths of
four men
stemming from an alleged cocaine drug
conspiracy so this is the guy who
ebstein was housed with
right in that prison he didn't kill
anybody he killed four people no he
didn't
what does it say he didn't kill him he's
charged he was charged
in a conspiracy with the deaths of four
men with in drugs right okay
right so i was a part of conspiracy it
was a rico
doing cocaine or doing heroin doing some
kind of drug and they
charge me with their deaths i know a guy
that got 20 a guy named brandon who got
like 25 or 30 years
because he actually you know what he did
25 years because he made the mistake of
going to trial here's why brandon went
to prison
because he was a bouncer at a bar and a
chick came in and said hey brandon do
you know anybody that sells heroin and
he said yes i do
i actually do know a guy here's his
phone number she went and bought heroin
from the guys
he she owed they grabbed the [ __ ]
dealer dealer calls back how'd you get
in touch with them
brandon sometimes will give people my
number if they need drugs
and so brandon uh brandon gave me the
number and they come and they indict
brandon
and say well you're you're gonna plead
guilty to like five or ten years
or you can go to trial but it's for this
murder and he says
[ __ ] you i just gave him a number i
didn't know she was gonna die didn't
know that he goes to trial boom he loses
he gets like 25 years